I'm just curious of all the roles that
you've played is there one that you hear
about the most or that has changed your
life the most um well you know I it's
funny because I I think there's a couple
of like kind of turning points you know
certainly footless was a big turning
point for me and then I got this part in
JFK and that really was when it came out
I felt a real shift and I think the
shift was that it was such a strong
character and people and I had always
thought of myself as a character actor
but I think because of Footloose people
kind of thought of me as like a you know
a pretty boy kind of you know pops mark
you know and and it's not really Who I
am you know and so JFK was really
important to get people sight reciting
lines from that movie to you yeah people
say lines to me from movies that I don't
even remember sometimes they'll go like
hey pass the salt and I'll be like I
don't even know what you're talking
about
we all remember you and pass the salt
JFK was was crazy we had the scene where
it's very I mean I use a lot of really
foul language
okay we're on we're on a zoom right now
so yeah right okay back then there was
the airline looping that you had to do
with you you had to find a phrase that
would fit with your lips for every
single curse that you would do and and
it was always this kind of challenging
sort of thing and I'll never forget
there's a scene where I'm talking to
Kevin Costner and I'm saying you don't
know [ __ ] mr. garcin because you never
bet and yeah I mean if you look at my
lips it's like I mean it's kind of like
hot what are you gonna put in there and
we're sitting around on a looping stage
and everyone's like what could it be
and the first thing we have to change is
the [ __ ] and that has to become squat
right that's an easy washer yeah it's
pretty tough to figure out so I ended up
saying you don't know squat much the gas
cuz you've never been loved by man
have you ever see the clean version of
mr. garrison cuz you never had to mow
the grass like